so here's a perfect example of the media
misunderstanding their
role in the current debate not
understanding their own bias so h.r
mcmaster the former national security
adviser to president trump
he was on cnn and he was talking
about media polarization he said you
know we have a couple different sets of
media they are catering to completely
different audiences
and mcmaster was talking about media
polarization
and jake tapper responded by saying that
no there's no me
you know it's really only polarization
from one side if you want lies then you
don't come here
hmm yes if you if it's true cnn
is completely down the middle only
people who want the truth go to cnn
i mean honestly i like jake personally
this is so out of touch with reality
here here's hr mcmaster and jake tapper
we have to look at your profession jake
the media you know why is it
that that people who lean in one
direction politically watch one cable
news station
some who lean in another direction watch
yours or another one
okay i mean the only i don't want to get
into a conversation about cnn that we
have a whole show that does that called
reliable sources but i will say
there are channels in which lies are
told and there are channels in which
facts are told and people who want the
lies they don't come here
they go to a different channel um no
actually
people who want a particular point of
view go to cnn and msnbc and people who
want another political point of view go
to fox news or newsmax or oann
and guess what it turns out that members
of the media regardless of point of view
will sometimes disseminate lies
they will they'll run with the story how
many months did we hear that jacob blake
was an unarmed black man shot
his shot nearly to death by police for
no reason other than race
a lot of months right turned out that
was completely false okay but
again it doesn't matter it's this
perception it's this this self-righteous
perception of the media
that allows them to push forward with
the idea that everybody else should just
be shut down
okay and this is extended to the this is
extended to those who are in the
the legislative community so alexander
ocasio-cortez who is of course the id of
the democratic party she says what all
the
democrats apparently are thinking but
won't say out loud because it's too
stupid
here's representative alexander
ocasio-cortez d-twitch
who said that she has now demanded
resignations she's demanding well whoop
dee
whoop do you frickin do she's demanding
resignations and i demand her
resignation
wow is it working no that's not how
anything works here
anyway here is aoc suggesting oh sorry i
can't call her aoc apparently it's
sexist or something even that's her
twitter handle representative alexander
ocasio-cortez the most honorable of all
congress people
suggesting that it's time to demand
resignations of like everyone she
disagrees with all of them
i have demanded the resignations of
senators
ted cruz senators josh hawley
majority leader republican majority or
rather republican minority leader in the
house
mccarthy kevin mccarthy and
along with with many others
because this is not just about
political opinion or partisanship
this was about the abandonment
of our sworn oath
yeah when i think somebody who really
shows feel to you to the constitution of
the united states it's the person who
believes
literally said last week that congress
should quote unquote reign in the media
okay i feel like that dry ramen guy
might point up to the text of the
constitutional first amendment
literally says congress shall make no
law
but don't worry it's all about
fealty it's not about partisanship you
see
because she's a totally objective source
according to herself
the lack of self-awareness is truly
incredible i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the ben shapiro show if you did go
ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content